a course in Pakistan's capital has
canceled former prime minister Imran
Khan's arrest warrants his supporters
clashed with police outside the court in
Islamabad and outside his home in Lahore
the case was adjourned and Khan was
ordered to reappear at a hearing on
March the 30th he faces a number of
legal cases which he says are
politically motivated
meanwhile in Lahore police entered the
home of the former prime minister
breaking through the front gate as
officers and card supporters clashed in
the street these 60 arrests were made
authorities say a search of the property
revealed weapons and a large amount of
ammunition Kamal Haider reports from
Islamabad
Pakistan's political choices sometimes
are not made at The Ballot Box and Imran
Khan has so many cases against him which
shows that the government is determined
uh to jail him to nail him somehow or
the other primarily because of his
Rising popularity and the opposition
between the Pakistan Democratic Alliance
and Imran Khan's party is one of the
most popular leaders in the country
however with all the cases they raid
against him there are fears that the
government wants to marginalize him
perhaps disqualify him arrest him use
whatever method that is according to
Imran Khan to nullify him so that they
can have a clean sweep at the elections
which are due in the Punjab on the 30th
and then within the country the national
elections in October so it's very
difficult to say whether Imran Khan will
be able to so wipe the storm he
certainly determined he has been
determined and has always said that he
is willing to go to any limit in order
to try and Achieve his objectives and of
course he's always been saying that he
wants this done peacefully
constitutionally